north Korea has backed off its threat to
launch a nuclear missile at Guam they
back off yeah
so now now the title of crazy tyrant
must lightly destroy America returns the
defending champion Donald Trump that was
one of the few people okay yeah you
would say wanted something yeah tough
times for the president a lot of CEOs
are deserting President Trump you heard
about this today President Trump
dissolved his advisory council because a
bunch of CEOs dropped out Trump said
they didn't take their job seriously
yeah Trump then went back to golfing and
retweeting memes while sitting on the
toilet so that's hard to do by the way
you're good at it I can't do it I know I
can even golf from the toilet I've seen
him do it he's very good today the Trump
administration named a new interim
communications director her name is hope
Hicks yeah yeah so apparently now
they're on the h's they're working just
we've got
[Music]
that means it's gonna be me and then
it's gonna be you yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm down the alphabet great
communications directing it changing my
name to Zorro you just don't want any
problems
yeah all right I want part of that no it
is true Hicks said her goal as
communications director are to highlight
the president's accomplishments engage
with the press and last longer than
eleven days that would be interesting
story last night the city of Baltimore
removed four statues of Confederate
heroes or or as Fox News reported it
baltimore Liberals forced pigeons from
their homes
thanks for trying
I appreciate its a little group in the
back through like I think that deserved
I said that deserve war and we're gonna
screw it in Washington DC yesterday
vandals spray-painted graffiti on the
Lincoln Memorial yeah historians are
calling it the second worst thing to
ever happen to Abraham Lincoln now guys
it's been a long time don't applaud it
now you've gone too far
all right you can laugh or you can but
to going yeah he got shot that was going
too far I know I know I know
yeah I think this crowd night we're
working it out yeah we're working it out
we're coming together like both
Americans should hey finally some good
news check this out today all McDonald's
in Canada are offering 67 cent burgers
yeah as if Americans need yet another
reason to move to Canada
let's go
[Music]
that's how I'm gonna get to Canada is
run like this I don't know why I'm
running like Jerry Lewis I don't know
they're not gonna let me in that's a big
assumption
you